.
I WILL CHECK IN LATER WITH
LAWRENCE LATER IN THE SHOW.
BRING IN NOW REPUBLICAN GOVERNOR
FROM GEORGIA BRIAN KEMP.
GOOD MORNING, GOVERNOR, THANKS
FOR BEING WITH US.
AINSLEY: GOOD MORNING, GOVERNOR.
>> GOOD MORNING, GUYS.
WILL: WE WANT TO GET YOUR TAKE
ON THIS WHILE WE HAVE YOU HERE
THIS MORNING.
XAVIER BECERRA HEAD OF HHS IS
WALKING BACK COMMENTS HE MADE
YESTERDAY.
FIRST ON CNN HE SAID THE
GOVERNMENT ABSOLUTELY HAS A
RIGHT TO KNOW WHO IS AND IS NOT
VACCINATED.
HERE'S WHAT HE HAD TO SAY
YESTERDAY THAT HE HAS SINCE
BEGUN TO REEL BACK.
IN FIRST, HIS AFFERENTS.
>> THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT HAS
HAD TO SPEND TRILLIONS OF
DOLLARS TO TRY TO KEEP MILLIONS
OF LIVES DURING THIS PANDEMIC IT
IS THE GOVERNMENT'S BUSINESS.
WE WANT TO GIVE PEOPLE THE SENSE
THAT THEY HAVE THE FREEDOM TO
CHOOSE.
WE HOPE TO CHOOSE TO LIVE.
WE HOPE PEOPLE MAKE THE RIGHT
CHOICES.
WE WANT THEM TO HAVE THE RIGHT
INFORMATION.
WE ARE AMERICA.
WE TRY TO GIVE PEOPLE AS MUCH
FREEDOM AND CHOICE AS POSSIBLE.
BUT, CLEARLY, WHEN OVER 600,000
AMERICANS HAVE DIED, THE BEST
CHOICE IS TO GET VACCINATED.
WILL: WHEN EVERYONE HEARS THEIR
SAYING WE WANT TO GIVE PEOPLE
THE SENSE TO HAVE THE FREEDOM TO
CHOOSE AND THE GOVERNMENT
DEFINITELY HAS THE RIGHT TO KNOW
WHETHER OR NOT YOU ARE
VACCINATED.
WHAT'S YOUR REACTION?
>> WELL, LISTEN, I THINK THAT'S
THE WRONG APPROACH, ESPECIALLY
RIGHT NOW IN THE PANDEMIC WITH
MIXED MESSAGES THAT HAVE BEEN
COMING OUT OF WASHINGTON LATELY
ON A LOT OF THINGS, INCLUDING
THE VACCINES.
YOU KNOW, I THINK THE PEOPLE
THAT HAVEN'T GOTTEN VACCINATED
JUST DON'T HAVE A LOT OF TRUST
IN THE GOVERNMENT.
AND I CERTAINLY UNDERSTAND THAT
WHAT I HAVE BEEN TELLING PEOPLE
IS WE DON'T NEED A GOVERNMENT
MANDATE.
WE NEED PEOPLE TO TALK TO YOUR
DOCTOR.
TALK TO THE FOLKS AT YOUR
HOSPITAL.
ASK THEM, YOU KNOW, OF COVID
PATIENTS THAT ARE COMING IN NOW,
ARE THEY VACCINATED OR NOT?
DO YOU THINK THE VACCINE IS
HELPING?
ASK YOUR DOCTOR THAT.
ASK YOUR LOCAL PHARMACY THAT ASK
YOUR FAMILY MEMBERS THAT HAVE
BEEN VACCINATED.
OR YOUR FAITH LEADERS OR OTHER
PEOPLE.
WE DON'T NEED, YOU KNOW, A
TYRANT IN GOVERNMENT THAT'S
GOING TO GO AROUND AND DO THIS.
THAT SCARES PEOPLE.
I THINK IT PERSONALLY RUNS THEM
OFF FROM TRUSTING THE VACCINE.
SO THAT'S MY MESSAGE BACK TO
THEM.
AINSLEY: ESPECIALLY WHEN HE
CHANGES HIS TUNE.
ORIGINALLY HE IS SAYING IT'S
ABSOLUTELY THE GOVERNMENT'S
BUSINESS, AND THEN HE TWEETED
OUT LATER IN THE DAY YESTERDAY
AFTERNOON, SOME COMMENTS I MADE
TODAY ARE BEING TAKEN WILDLY OUT
OF CONTEXT.
TO BE CLEAR, GOVERNMENT HAS NO
DATABASE TRACKING WHO IS
VACCINATED.
WE'RE ENCOURAGING PEOPLE TO
ACCEPT UP TO PROTECT THEMSELVES
AND OTHERS BY GETTING
VACCINATED.
IT'S THE BEST WAY TO SAVE LIVES
AND END THIS PANDEMIC.
IS THAT WHY YOU THINK PEOPLE
DON'T TRUST THE GOVERNMENT?
THEY SAY ONE THING, WE KNOW WHAT
THEY ACTUALLY MEAN BUT THEN THEY
CORRECT IT LATER?
>> NO DOUBT ABOUT IT LOTS OF
MIXED MESSAGES OUT THERE.
WE'RE NOT GOING TO BE TRACKING
ANYBODY IN THE STATE OF GEORGIA.
YOU KNOW, MY HOME FAMILY HAS
BEEN VACCINATED.
I FEEL VERY COMFORTABLE WITH
THAT BUT THAT'S AN INDIVIDUAL
CHOICE, ESPECIALLY FOR THE
PEOPLE THAT ARE LEFT THAT HAVE
NOT BEEN VACCINATED.
THEY HAVE GOT TO GET COMFORTABLE
MAKING THAT AMERICA DECISION FOR
THEMSELVES.
AND I BELIEVE THEY CAN DO THAT
IF THEY WILL SIMPLY TAKE A FEW
MINUTES AND TALK TO THEIR
MEDICAL PROFESSIONALS.
BRIAN: I DON'T START GIVING
MEDICAL ADVICE ALL OF THE SUDDEN
I SAY I GOT VACCINATED YOU CAN
TAKE FROM THAT WHAT YOU WANT.
IT'S UP TO YOU.
I MIGHT CHOOSE TO GO CLIFF
DIVING.
I DON'T WANT PEOPLE TELLING ME I
CAN'T.
DR. JONATHAN REINER HAS A
DIFFERENT TAKE ON THAT,
GOVERNOR.
LISTEN TO THIS.
>> I DO THINK IT'S TIME TO START
MANDATING VACCINES.
AND I THINK THAT PRIVATE
INDUSTRY AND PRIVATE
ORGANIZATIONS WILL DO THAT
75 MILLION ADULTS HAVE CHOSEN
NOT TO GET VACCINATED.
AND THAT CHOICE HAS
CONSEQUENCES.
NOW, WE CAN'T FORCE YOU TO TAKE
A JAB IN THE ARM, BUT THERE ARE
MANY JOBS, PERHAPS, THAT CAN
PREVENT YOU FROM WORKING IF YOU
DECIDE NOT TO GET VACCINATED.
BRIAN: YOU COMFORTABLE WITH
THAT?
>> NO.
LISTEN.
THAT'S A DECISION THAT I BELIEVE
INDIVIDUALS NEED TO MAKE,
PRIVATE EMPLOYERS NEED TO MAKE.
I DON'T ALWAYS AGREE WITH THOSE
DECISIONS, BUT I HAVE ALWAYS
BEEN CONSISTENT.
WE DON'T NEED THE GOVERNMENT
MANDATING THESE THINGS ON A
PERSON OR A PRIVATE BUSINESS.
I HAVE BEEN A SMALL BUSINESS
OWNER FOR 35 YEARS.
I DON'T WANT THE GOVERNMENT
TELLING ME, YOU KNOW, WHETHER I
NEED TO VACCINATE MY EMPLOYEES
OR NOT.
I JUST DON'T THINK WE NEED TO BE
IN THAT BUSINESS.
I THINK IF YOU SEE THAT HAPPEN,
YOU ARE GOING TO SEE PEOPLE
REVOLT, YOU KNOW, LIKE THEY HAVE
BEEN DOING ON AIRPLANES ON
WHETHER TO WEAR A MASK NOW OR OR
NOT AND PEOPLE ARE FIGHTING OVER
THAT I CAN'T IMAGINE WHAT IT
WOULD BE LIKE IF WE START DOING
SOMETHING LIKE THAT WITH
VACCINES.
BRIAN: K THROUGH 12 GET
VACCINATED THERE WILL BE A WAR
THERE WILL I WILL I HOPE YOU
WILL FORGIVE ME FOR A BIT OF A
WINDUP.
I HAVE BEEN WATCHING A
DOCUMENTARY ON EDWARD BENET
GODFATHER OF PROPAGANDA AND P.R.
CONTROL PEOPLE'S CHOICES THROUGH
MANIPULATION AND PROPAGANDA.
VACCINE EFFORT PART OF THAT PUSH
TO CONTROL WHAT CHOICES WE MAKE.
IT'S ALSO HOW YOU PUSH A
MESSAGE.
VICE PRESIDENT KAMALA HARRIS
SUGGESTED DEMOCRATS ARE GOING TO
INVEST $25 MILLION IN PAINTING
REPUBLICAN LAWS LIKE YOUR
GEORGIA LAW TO INCREASE VOTER
INTEGRITY AS VOTER SUPPRESSION.
THIS IS A FULL-ON PUSH, A
PROPAGANDA PUSH.
AND YOU KNOW THIS VERY WELL
BECAUSE IT'S BEEN SOMEWHAT
SUCCESSFUL, A PUSH TO
CHARACTERIZE YOUR LAW, I WANT
YOU TO LISTEN TO VICE PRESIDENT
KAMALA HARRIS VERY QUICKLY ON
THIS NEW PUSH.
>> IN 2020, YOU WERE HEARD,
AMERICA.
YOU WERE HEARD LOUD AND CLEAR.
BUT, THERE IS ANOTHER SIDE TO
THIS STORY.
SO FAR THIS YEAR 17 STATE
LEGISLATIVE LEGISLATION LAY
TEMPERATURES ENACTED 28 NEW LAWS
THAT WILL MAKE IT HARDER FOR
AMERICANS TO VOTE.
THESE BILLS NOW, BE CLEAR --
THESE BILLS HAVE ALREADY BECOME
LAW.
THEY ARE NOW ON THE BOOKS.
THIS ALL IS DESIGNED, I BELIEVE,
TO MAKE IT HARDER FOR YOU TO
VOTE SO THAT YOU DON'T VOTE.
WILL: MAKE IT HARDER FOR YOU TO
VOTE, CALL IT VOTER SUPPRESSION.
CALL IT RACIST.
GOVERNOR, YOU A PROPAGANDA WAR.
HOW DO YOU WIN THIS?
>> HEY, WE GOT TO FIGHT LIKE
HELL.
THAT'S WHAT I HAVE BEEN TELLING
PEOPLE.
WE HAD THE TRUTH ON OUR SIDE.
NOW THE VICE PRESIDENT IS LYING
LIKE THE PRESIDENT HAS BEEN
ABOUT GEORGIA'S LAW.
WE ACTUALLY ADD THE AMOUNT OF
DAYS THAT PEOPLE CAN VOTE EARLY
ON THE WEEKENDS IN THE STATE OF
GEORGIA.
WE HAVE GOT MANY MORE
OPPORTUNITIES FOR PEOPLE TO VOTE
EARLY THAN PRESIDENT BIDEN'S OWN
STATE OF DELAWARE AND A LOT OF
OTHER STATES WHERE THE DEMOCRATS
ARE IN CONTROL.
THEY ARE JUST NOT BEING TRUTHFUL
TO PEOPLE.
AND, LISTEN, THIS IS JUST PART
OF THEIR PLAYBOOK.
THEIR LEGISLATION FAILED AT
CONGRESS TO HAVE A FEDERAL
TAKEOVER OF ELECTIONS, WHICH IS
UNCONSTITUTIONAL.
NOW THEY HAD THE DEPARTMENT OF
JUSTICE, WHEN WE HAVE, YOU KNOW,
VIOLENT CRIME, KILLINGS IN MAJOR
CITIES ALL OVER THE COUNTRY, A
CRISIS AT THE BORDER, AND THE
FIGHT THEY ARE PICKING IS SUING
US OVER OUR ELECTIONS INTEGRITY
ACT.
THEY REALIZE NOW AFTER THE
ARIZONA RULING THAT'S NOT GOING
TO WORK.
NOW THEY ARE MOVING TO THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY AT THE NATIONAL
LEVEL TRYING TO SPEND
$25 MILLION TO CANCEL US.
MY MESSAGE IS, LOOK, WE ARE
GOING TO STAND UP AND FIGHT.
WE HAVE THE TRUTH ON OUR SIDE.
BUT YOU NEED TO BE AWARE THEY
ARE GOING TO TRY TO CANCEL YOU.
THEY ARE GOING TO TRY TO BOYCOTT
YOUR BUSINESS, MOVE YOUR
BALLGAME JUST LIKE THEY DID THE
ALL-STAR GAME GAME IN GEORGIA.
THEY ARE GOING TO COME AFTER
YOUR WAY OF LIFE.
THIS ISN'T A FIGHT JUST IN
GEORGIA.
THIS IS A NATIONWIDE FIGHT.
IT IS ONE WORTH FIGHTING.
AND THAT IS WHAT I'M GOING TO
CONTINUE TO DO.
WILL: PROPAGANDA WORKED.
IT INFLUENCED MAJOR LEAGUE
BASEBALL TO PULL THEIR GAME AS
YOU MENTIONED OUT OF GEORGIA AND
PART OF THAT TIGHT BACK CLEARLY
IS YOU GUYS HAVE PUT TOGETHER AN
AD SLAMMING MAJOR LEAGUE
BASEBALL FOR THAT DECISION.
LET'S TAKE A LOOK AT THE AD
REALLY QUICKLY.
>> THIS WEEK WE SHOULD BE
CELEBRATING BASEBALL.
INSTEAD, STACEY ABRAMS AND THE
LIBERAL MOB FORCED THE ALL-STAR
GAME TO MOVE DESPITE THE FACT WE
MADE IT EASIER TO VOTE.
AINSLEY: SO, GOVERNOR, WE WANT
TO TALK ABOUT CRIME WHICH SAN
ISSUE THAT I KNOW YOUR FOLKS ARE
REALLY WORRIED ABOUT, ATLANTA
AREA ESPECIALLY AND THEN RIGHT
OUTSIDE OF ATLANTA KENNESAW,
GEORGIA.
THE GOLF PRO-WAS KILLED ON THE
GOLF COURSE AND I KNOW SOMEONE
WHO LIVES ON THAT GOLF COURSE
AND HE SAYS THE GOLF
PRO-ACTUALLY LIVES THERE HE HAS
TWO LITTLE KIDS.
THERE IS A MEMORIAL FOR HIM.
CRIME IS GOING UP EVERYWHERE.
HOW DO YOU -- HOW, AS GOVERNOR,
CAN YOU COMBAT THIS?
>> WELL, FIRST OF ALL, OUR
THOUGHTS AND PRAYERS GO OUT TO
THE SILER FAMILY.
I MEAN, THAT IS JUST A TRAGIC
EVENT, WRONG PLACE AT THE WRONG
TIME TO A GOOD MAN AND A GREAT
FAMILY AND WE'LL CONTINUE TO
HAVE THEM IN OUR PRAYERS.
I APPRECIATE THE COBB COUNTY
POLICE DEPARTMENT CHIEF COX FOR
GETTING THIS TERRIBLE PERSON OFF
THE STREETS TO PROTECT ALL
GEORGIANS AND OTHER PEOPLE
ARRANGED THE COUNTRY.
BUT, LOOK, THIS IS HAPPENING IN
MAJOR CITIES.
NUMBER ONE, BECAUSE WE DON'T
HAVE THE DEMOCRATS SUPPORTING
LOCAL LAW ENFORCEMENT AND
STANDING SHOULDER TO SHOULDER
AND BEHIND THEM TO BACK THEM UP.
PUTTING BOOTS ON THE GROUND
WORKS.
I GOT SO FED UP WITH THIS ALMOST
THREE MONTHS AGO NOW I ASKED
COLONEL WRIGHT WITH THE GEORGIA
STATE PATROL TO COME UP WITH A
PLAN TO HELP US ASSIST THE
ATLANTA POLICE DEPARTMENT.
THEY ARE WORKING WITH THEIR
HANDS TIED BEHIND THEIR BACK BUT
THEY ARE DOING EVERYTHING THEY
CAN TO SUPPORT US.
WE HAVE MADE A LOT OF HEADWAY
GOING AFTER STREET RACERS.
VIOLENT CRIMINALLERS.
THE SPEAKER RALSTON GEORGIA
GENERAL ASSEMBLY HOLDING
HEARINGS TO SEE WHAT ELSE WE CAN
DO.
NOT ONLY SUPPORT LAW ENFORCEMENT
BUT GO AFTER AS A STATE THESE
INDIVIDUALS WHEN LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS WON'T DO THAT WE
ALSO PASSED A BILL THIS YEAR TO
KEEP ROGUE LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
FROM DEFUNDING THE POLICE.
WE HAVE GOT STAND WITH OUR LAW
ENFORCEMENT PERSONNEL AND TAKE
THE FIGHT TO THESE INDIVIDUALS
AND SHOW THEM THAT WE ARE NOT
GOING TO PUT UP WITH THIS.
WE ALSO HAVE TO HOLD THOSE BAD
ACTORS ACCOUNTABLE, WHICH WE
SHOULD DO AND THAT'S EXACTLY
WHAT WE'RE GOING TO DO IN
GEORGIA.
BRIAN: THAT'S SO TYPICAL IT
SEEMS LIKE STATES ARE AT WAR
WITH THEIR OWN CITIES.
HOW DO YOU FEEL ABOUT BUCK HEAD
SPINNING OUT AND TRYING TO GET
THEIR INDEPENDENCE FROM ATLANTA
AND HAVE THEIR OWN POLICE FORCE?
ARE YOU SUPPORTING THAT?
>> WELL, I CERTAINLY, YOU KNOW,
GOING TO BE AN INTERESTING FIGHT
THERE, IF YOU WILL.
THE STUDIES ARE GOING ON NOW.
THERE IS A GROUP THAT'S VERY
PASSIONATE ABOUT THAT.
THERE IS A LOT OF THINGS TO
CONSIDER THERE WHICH I CERTAINLY
WILL DO AND SEE WHERE THE
LEGISLATURE ENDS UP ON THAT.
BUT THE FACT OF THE MATTER IS I
UNDERSTAND WHY THEY ARE DOING IT
THEY ARE FED UP.
I MEAN, JUST TWO NIGHTS AGO
THERE WAS SOMEBODY THAT WAS
LITERALLY BLOCKED FROM THE
GOVERNOR'S MANSION IN THE HEART
OF BUCK HEAD DOING HOME
INVASIONS.
I WAS -- HAD BREAKFAST WITH A
GROUP THE OTHER DAY AT AN
ESTABLISHMENT UP THE STREET FROM
THE GOVERNOR'S MANSION.
THEY HAVE ARMED SECURITY GUARDS,
TWO OF THEM, IN THE PARKING
LOTS.
THEY HAVE HAD SO MANY CARS
BROKEN INTO AND STOLEN AND OTHER
THINGS.
I MEAN, PEOPLE ARE FED UP.
THEY ARE OUTRAGED.
BUT, EVEN WORSE, THEY ARE SCARED
AND THEY WANT SOMETHING DONE.
AND I THINK THEY ARE SENDING
THAT MESSAGE TO THE MAYOR AND
THE CITY OF ATLANTA THAT THEY
DEMAND THAT AND THAT'S WHAT THE
CAMPAIGN FOR THE MAYOR'S RACE
THIS YEAR IS GOING TO BE ABOUT
IN THE CITY OF ATLANTA.
AINSLEY: WE ALSO WANT TO ASK YOU
ABOUT TROPICAL STORM ELSA.
I KNOW THAT 10 WERE INJURED IN
GEORGIA AT A NAVY BASE.
WHAT HE WAS THE LATEST ON THAT?
>> YEAH, WE GOT -- LISTEN, WE
HAD JUST A REALLY SPOTTY STORM
THAT HIT KING'S BAY DOWN THERE.
THANKFULLY NO ONE HAD LOSS OF
LIFE AS OF YET.
THERE IS ONE CRITICALLY INJURED
PERSON.
THE REST OF THEM WERE, I THINK,
FAIRLY MINOR INJURIES, WHICH IS
A BLESSING AND OUR PRAYERS GO
OUT TO ALL OF THOSE THAT HAVE
BEEN AFFECTED NOT ONLY HERE BUT
IN THE STATE OF FLORIDA AS WELL.
BUT, WE HAVE GOT A LOT OF STATE
RESOURCES DOWN THERE HELPING
CLEARING ROADS, THE POWER
COMPANIES HAVE MADE GREAT
HEADWAY GETTING POWER RESTORED.
AND ALL IN ALL, COMPARED TO WHAT
HAPPENED IN FLORIDA, WE GOT VERY
LUCKY THE OTHER NIGHT IN
GEORGIA.
BUT WE HAVE A LOT OF FOLKS ON
THE GROUND RESPONDING AS WE
SPEAK.
WILL: GOVERNOR BRIAN KEMP OF
GEORGIA.
WE APPRECIATE YOUR TIME AND
PERSPECTIVE TH